un nom en forme d'évidence celle d'un
champion français pour nommer l'antre du
cyclisme sur piste plus de deux ans
après son inauguration le vélodrome de
saint quentin est désormais bordée par
la rue laurent fignon un bel hommage
pour le double vainqueur du tour de
france et son épouse présente pour
l'occasion c'est compliqué pour moi
d'être de représenter laurent parce qu'à
chaque fois ça me montre qu'il n'est
plus là je suis fier de voir tous ces
gens qui m'en parlent encore tous ces
gens qui sont rassemblées aujourd'hui
pour cette inauguration et de le voir
sur un panneau de rue c'est vrai que ça
fait bizarre mais je suis fier malgré
tout présent également michel logis
maire de montigny le bretonneux et
thierry braillard secrétaire d'état aux
sports qui a tenu à saluer la mémoire du
cycliste décédé d'un cancer il ya six
ans c'est un champion qui n'a pas laissé
indifférent
j'avais il ya des champions qui dans la
différentes disciplines pour gagner des
titres et puis quelle est un prêt on
s'en souvient plus là vous rendez compte
plus de vingt ans après on se souvient
encore de la façon dont laurent fignon a
gagné sept tours de france a été gagné
le tour d'italie a gagné milan san remo
c'était un grand champion campus avait
une personnalité elle l'inauguration de
la rue laurent fignon s'est déroulé
pendant les championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste à porte bonheur
sûrement pour le camp tricolore qui a
glané sept médailles en quatre jours